داخل سيارة نقود ونقل ترانزيت
قبل لحظات من الكمين خلف
عجلة القيادة ،
وهو فريق عمل خاص سابق للشرطة ،
ليو برينسلو ،
إنه أول أسبوع يقضيه زميله
في العمل ، قالت شركة النقل إنها
واحدة من أخطر الوظائف في جنوب
إفريقيا ولهذا السبب
أطلق المسلحون النار.  -47s من
سيارة سيدان فخمة مسرعة
يحاولون قتل الأمير لو أطلق النار
على إطاراته على طريق سريع في
العاصمة
بريتوريا ،
قام بإبعاد السيارة عن الطريق ولكن
التهديد لم ينته بعد ،
أخبرنا خبراء الأمن أن هذا
هو عمل المجرم
باستخدام ما لا يقل عن أربع مركبات مع
العديد من المسلحين
يشاهدون عندما تأتي سيارة بيك آب بيضاء
من اليسار
، يحاولون طلب النسخ الاحتياطي في كثير من الأحيان يدفعون النقود
وفرق النقل
مقابل حياتهم في هذا اليوم
كانوا يحملون هواتف محمولة ،
وكان هناك أكثر من 150 عملية سرقة مثل
هذه في الجنوب  إفريقيا العام الماضي
وحده وفقًا لبيانات الشرطة في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية فقط ،
صدمت العديد من الحوادث الدراماتيكية مثل هذا الحادث في كيب تاون سكان جنوب إفريقيا القادم.
تمت الإشادة برأسه الهادئ
وسرعة تفكيره
في أن الشرطة لم تقم بأي اعتقالات في
الهجوم
ديفيد ماكنزي سي إن جوهانسبرج